I think that
Millennials and gen Z are doe soy boys
for the most part and that's why they're
entitled that's why they cry and
complain that's why they vote for
ridiculous policy that makes no sense
that's why California is is now
proposing reparations despite the fact
California is a free state and has
always been a free state it was admitted
as a free state and there and and the
best part is you only have to identify
as black you don't have to actually be
it's crazy isn't it so Rachel dolezal so
Rachel dolezal only she would qualify if
she lived there if you live there okay
so if Rachel dolezal lived in San
Francisco for 13 years and had a family
member that was incarcerated due to the
War on Drugs she would qualify for the
five million dollars
none of it makes any sense these people
need to experience a cold winter where
someone comes in and says it's time to
chop wood or we freeze to death and then
they can realize what a good day of hard
work really means and why you should not
steal from other people Wilderness
Survival Camp
well I don't know all I'm saying is
these are people who are voting to steal
from people they're saying the
reparations are going to cost six
hundred thousand dollars per per family
in San Francisco to cover the cost of
the reparations so what they're doing is
they're saying if you identify as black
not if you are
and you're over 18. you then have to
qualify for two of eight different
criteria one of which is you're the
descendant of somebody who was enslaved
in the United States despite the fact
that California's a free state one of
them is have a descendant or yourself be
incarcerated due to the War on Drugs
which is nebulous what does that even
mean but there's still I went to jail
for marijuana so they're still putting
people away for for using drugs in
California well that's that's that's
that's one uh one box checked and then
if uh so what was it what was the other
one you have to uh be incarcerated or
have a family member who's incarcerated
and then what was the other one I just
said I lived in San Francisco for a
certain amount of time 15 years so you
could go you could intentionally get
arrested for on a drug charge go serve a
little bit of time get out and be like
five million dollars yes amazing if you
live in SF for at least 13 years and you
identify identify as black for at least
10 years and are over 18. then yeah that
is a get rich that is a get rich scheme
well I don't know if they're actually
going to do it but I don't it it doesn't
I hope they do I absolutely since I've
moved out I'm kind of like burn it all
down I feel very bitter about what they
did to California I'm like go ahead and
burn
we moved in September we moved to Austin
Texas where what city were you in uh L.A
uh briefly for a little bit of time in
Newport Beach which is a really nice
area but same tax rates you know
everything else and it was creeping in
this is why oh what's last thing you
said everything else about California
was creeping in you know these
reparations you might think it's going
to repair something which is what the
word reparation is supposed to entail
but it's going to create many more
problems if you take six hundred
thousand dollars from one family and
then give it to another family the
government does that you don't think
that's going to create animosity between
the people that got 600 000 taken
especially when you I mean it's going to
bankrupt the city no matter what even if
you take money away from someone else so
you are hurting everyone who's there and
giving wealth to some people just to
create a city where it's chaos I mean it
doesn't make any sense all right so I
got it right here here's here's the list
you must be an individual who has
identified as black or African-American
on public documents for at least 10
years you must be at least 18 years or
older then you must also meet two of
these eight criteria and be able to
prove it born in San Francisco between
1940 and 96 and have proof of residency
for at least 13 years migrated to SF
between 1940 and 1996 and have proof of
residency for at least 13 years
personally or the direct descendant of
someone incarcerated by the failed War
on Drugs record of attendance in San
Francisco public schools during the time
of the consent decree to complete
desegregation within the school system
descendant of someone enslaved through
U.S Channel slavery before 1865.
displaced or the direct descendant of
someone displaced listed or the direct
descendant of a certificate of
preference holder or member of a Mart oh
this one's great member of an
historically marginalized group that
experienced lending discrimination in
San Francisco between 1937 and 1968 or
subsequently experienced Landing
discrimination in the formerly redlined
San Francisco communities between 1968
and 2008. basically it's extremely easy
to qualify for the reparations program
so let's break it down
Rachel dolezal
if she identifies as black does that
mean she is a member of a marginalized
group
if the first criteria is only
identification and not actual genetic
testing she would also qualify for being
a member of a marginalized group then
because she identifies as such
she would then only need to live in San
Francisco before 1996.
so how many people live down there who
are like Rachel de luzov never been
found out who are going to get paid even
though they're like white as white can
be oh there's going to be so many oh
that's going to be a long line but it
sounds like if you identify if you're a
white person that identifies as black
that doesn't get you to become a member
of a marginalized Community which if
you're assuming it's a black community
so you only identify as it you're not
actually it so it's different no no no
no no no hold on this is why this is why
you're wrong if you look at the criteria
it's as an individual who is identified
as black African-American and public
documents for at least 10 years the main
criteria that you have to have is that
you have to be able oh okay and if that
is their hard-line standard then I
certainly believe the member of a
historically marginalized group is a
lower standard or or the same or the
same standard in which case if their
argument is you have to identify as
black I really doubt they would change
their view on what it means to be a
member for a different part of the same
crisis they're trying to lock out people
that are black that identify as white I
think that's the what that first by
letting in people who are white to
identify as black and I'm trying to
confirm it right now but I think Rachel
dolezal as a female could claim she's
part of a marginalized group oh yeah
boom there you go well I mean oh and
absolutely women explaining
discrimination no question left-handed
people
hold on women couldn't get credit cards
yeah San Francisco recognizes women or
sex discrimination as you know oh boom
so Rachel dolezal she is a member of
historically marginalized group she's
over 18 she identifies as black so what
else does she need she just needs to
have lived in San Francisco and she
would qualify for reparations dude that
is fantastic I hope they give this money
out seriously it doesn't have like an
income or a net worth criteria you can
no 45 million bucks and a one dollar
house how many people do you think
qualify who live in city man it's gonna
be funny because it's going to be like
half the city yeah it's amazing people
are going to be like first of all like
almost every woman qualifies
like that's just it it's gonna be worse
than a bank run there's Wild
but I guess you have to you have to
identify on public documents that you're
black so that's a big that's a big one
because you couldn't have foreseen this
I mean maybe some people could it's
pretty insulting to the black community
for people who are actual descendants
well we all know Rachel those all but I
wonder how many people have been
claiming they're black in San Francisco
for years right like she's the one who
got caught but that doesn't mean she is
the only person in America who's done
this like I think there will be so many
people yeah
he has never confirmed it the jury's out
on that one I don't know I can't I mean
he looks white and then there was that
document the police arrest report that
called them white I'm pretty sure my
buddy's a black albino talked about him
on the Victor Varnado shot what's up
Victor uh yeah albino dude he's white as
me but he's black dude apparently
whatever that means but his ancestry is
like African I believe it's wild and
there's I don't remember what what
country but there's a nation in Africa
that has the highest rate of albinism in
the world it's like just a genetic they
used to think they were witches and they
would like burn them at the stage even
now it's incredibly dangerous because
there's all kinds of like yeah of uh
I don't know what what to call it but
like lore about you know the the bones
or flesh of uh people who have albinism
wow
I hope they do the reparations you do
yeah because it'll be really funny to
watch from afar to see all the white
liberals be like the roads aren't paved
yeah and there's poop everywhere and
then they go to the City Hall meetings
and they're like why isn't this getting
done and they're going to be like
because we spent five trillion dollars
in taxpayer money to give people five
million dollars what did you think San
Francisco needs to be punished that
place needs to be punished God said he'd
never flood the Earth let's let's send
this reparations Bill instead you know
we should be careful about praying for
punishment to the city because there
might be an earthquake that thing's been
terrorized by the San Andreas fault line
let's not do that let's just make it uh
absurdity all right
there are as of 2021 815
000 people in San Francisco the Metro
itself is bigger five percent of that uh
population is black so giving us around
40 000 or so people so uh simply put
forty thousand times five million five
million
let's do some quick uh quick math there
and uh oh man that's a lot of zeros so
uh what is that 20 trillion what is that
20 trillion where is this number I think
it's uh I think it's is that 20 trillion
dollars that sounds fun so let me see
it's it's commas up in that
200 trillion 200 trillion 200 billion
I think it's 200 trillion
trillion
two everyone in the chat's gonna be like
dude it's 200 trillion they're doing the
math 200 trillion dollars that's not
even in existence just a regular number
okay to be fair not every single black
person in that city is going to qualify
right no no because you have to be
overrated but when you add in all of the
other people who are going to lie so
that they do qualify
could be even more than forty thousand I
mean the other part is like what if they
roll this out realize they can't you
know comply with the measures they put
out they have to say wait we're going
back to the drawing board and making
stricter regulations like then no no
it's 200 billion then the people who
thought they were going to get this
payout are going to be livid are you
sure yep I'm talking 200 trillion as
well it's right you said it was no it's
200 degrees right I'm sorry 5 million
times forty thousand two hundred billion
40 000 times 5 million 200 billion
dollars no no no that's that's trillion
no I'm pretty sure it's
200 billion dollars I'm intentionally
not looking 200 billion oh yeah you're
right 200 100 billion that's weird god
what the
well let's do let's do something else uh
100 billion that's not that much total
total budget for San Francisco
nice total SF budget
2022. it's uh 14 billion they're also
going to give homes out for one dollar
I would like everybody listening
to do the right thing
and advocate for San Francisco to
implement this policy make it happen
what if it works then great it's good
for them why would I be mad because then
they'll do it to your city no no wait
wait what but if it works okay all of a
sudden everyone's holding hands and
singing songs Under rainbows I'd be like
well I'll be damned yeah it worked it'll
be fine problem solved but it's not
going to work it's going to destroy San
Francisco and I'm here for it I'll get
the popcorn San Francisco's already
pretty shredded it's it's an awful place
there's poop everywhere it is look man
if they voted for it they deserve it the
first day I went to San Francisco I was
going to move there and I parked my car
and went to look at the apartment when I
came out my window was smashed and my
bag had been stolen with my laptop
everything lesson learned Man Dirty city
with a lot of desperate people yeah
that's so sad not so so hold on paying
four thousand dollars a month for a one
bedroom kidding me all right all right
let's say half those people are under
18. okay and half of the people who are
over 18 were not born there and don't
qualify so let's just say it's 50
billion okay
50 billion dollars is still you know
around what four times their their their
budget so but let's talk about the
houses as well let's say they've got
that's going to be uh what is that
that's that's ten thousand what's their
homeless population
uh the homeless population so they're
they're giving away one it's not it's
but yeah but it's not that I mean
somebody's got an apartment's going to
want a house too sure so let's just
let's just do the math and say
half are under 18 and of the remaining
20 half qualify so you've got 10 000
people and then what we'll do is
um ten thousand houses
and the average what's the average cost
of a house in San Francisco you want to
Google that real quick
take guesses minus 1.2 million yeah look
it up average house I feel like it's
it's higher it's got to be higher I feel
like it's maybe I'm gonna go 2.2 million
yeah in San Fran it's very it's very
small Jersey the average house cost in
San Francisco is around 350 000 no due
to the skyrocketing real estate and like
that I mean houses but like apartments
and stuff that's from fortune.com
um this is House cost 350 000 what for
your down payment
that's wild 1.2 million okay what the
Fortune 1.238 million San Francisco home
values down 10 percent Ian you are
spotting it is down 10 all right yeah so
I think I think you may be looking at
San Francisco Metro which is massive San
Francisco has it in and of itself is
1.23 1.35 million according to Red so
let's uh let's add that to the uh number
there
and it's another 12 billion oh so we're
looking at like I don't know about 60
billion dollars realistically yeah I'm
excited it would be good to give people
houses that want them because biggest
barrier entry a lot of times to get back
into society is getting a shower not
having access to clean water and a
shower if you can clean up easy to get a
job then you can get back on your feet
so it's like 350 000 people I want to
help people that's called like not to
bankrupt the entire city that's called
projects and they are usually not great
places to live if they're I think the
Russians were doing with Farmland
they're like if you want a Home Instead
for a year you can get what number would
you come up with they said it would cost
the average non-person of color in the
city around 600 000 so I did the the
rough math there's 44.9 white in in a
city of 815 000 which is like 300 and
some odd thousand three hundred and
fifty thousand times six hundred
thousand is 210 billion
it all adds up six hundred thousand
dollars per uh per a non-person of color
in San Francisco uh I I seriously hope
they do this because these people voted
for it do Asian and Latino people pay
the same amount I don't know I bet they
introduced a scale eventually
or like immigrants if you're like I I
just got here why would I have to pay
this so I'm not a fan of race Wars and
this is um
if if they voted for this then they
deserve it they do if you vote they do
to get a new playground put in your
community you deserve it it's a problem
with representative government it's not
going to only charge the 600 000 to the
people who voted in favor of these
things right like people who voted
against it will also have to pay for it
yeah dude if you want to live in a city
where they're telling you that you are
an evil white supremacist they're taking
your money and you're like okay I guess
well I'm not going to shed a tear for
you you got to move you got to move well
check this out check this out we have I
pulled up the demographics of San
Francisco 2020 it was 873 965 and then
2021 was 815 000 a drop of six percent
take a look at that what was the six
percent drop in what was it six percent
drop in population from 2020 to 2021.
people left yeah who wants to be there
that is a big drop I mean that's like
the last 10 years of growth lost in one
year smart people should migrate uh
you're right it absolutely is around 10
years of growth lost in one year wow and
where did they go oh Arizona yeah well
someone said well some went to Florida
the more conservative leaning ones but a
lot of them went to Arizona and turned
Arizona blue oh wait yeah no that's five
Decades of growth lost people who don't
learn that no no no no no no that's
that's look in 2010 it was 805 and 2020
was 873 and 2021 was 8 15. okay so it's
not five decades right uh yeah if you go
back five decades you're looking at 740
000. so you know the city hasn't hasn't
really grown that much you know what it
is
they're zombies yeah the left is a
zombie horde it's a zombie ideology
that's what's happening right now and
when they spread
they bring that to government so that's
why Arizona is turning blue because
people are fleeing California because
they're zombies it's so sad a lot of my
liberal friends have left California
moved to Arizona and they are voting and
behaving in the exact same ways when
they lived in California how do you feel
like sorry I was to say if as a person
who fled California for a red State like
do you feel like you get a bad rap
because you also left California well I
have a loophole because I grew up in
Texas oh okay never mind I moved to
California when I was a teenager with my
family so when people ask me where I'm
from I'm like Longview Texas you're like
I'm going back home yep yep failed
experiment how do you fortify
libertarianism against mob rule
guns
she's just you just threaten people no I
mean I'm just oversimplifying it I mean
give me give me like a scenario you mean
against mob rule I mean a well-armed
society is a polite Society like that's
not hyperbolic there's 10 000 of us all
armed
six thousand five thousand and ten of
them wanna redirect the Waterway to
their side of the city
I mean you got to work that out
there's not a lot of scenarios where we
in the modern present day era we've just
straight up go to war over a river we
usually have negotiations and policies
and you know dealing with things like
that but the reality is we don't live in
a Libertarian Society right now and if
we were in a Libertarian Society you're
going to be much less likely to to have
people just going and engaging in mob
Rule and taking over waterways thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time